there's a Drake what about the
allegations that your tests and killing
people you're finished well I think we
opened him up I have a reporter I found
something really bad
and I have been taken
cooperate and you just might survive why
would we do that
weren't you any prom
I used to me hey everybody happy trailer
week we got some new venom to break down
in the prequel comic book that they just
released in the last couple of days if
you didn't see it there is a comic book
that explains a little bit more about
what's going on with the symbiote why it
is he needs Eddie to survive and why
it's so important for Eddie to embrace
that there's a new route of that
spider-man ps4 game giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video uh name
a new winner at the end of this so the
whole comic book is dedicated to
explaining the relationship that you see
in that clip that I put at the beginning
of this where he starts talking to Eddie
do what I tell you listen to me and we
just might survive like that bargaining
scene where it's like why would I you
know want to help you what's going on
here the prequel comic confirms a bunch
of big things so we'll read through the
most important parts of this so it picks
up with that scene with Doris Kurt who's
played by Jenny Slade's character that
we saw in the trailer remember how
everyone was really upset by the way she
pronounced Cindy out and then they
changed it one of the later trailer
edits so it opens with her trying to
tail Eddie so that she can inform on
what's happening within the life
foundation because she is a scientist
that works for Carleton Drake so Eddie
catches her in the act of trying to tell
him and he says so I used to be a
reporter once I was pretty successful
job required you to follow a lot of
people who don't want to be followed
have to learn how to disappear how to
fade into the background hide in plain
sight and I got pretty good at it
you suck however you like even the
fundamental ability required to form
even the most basic covert existence
whoever you are my name is Doris gurth I
need your help I work at the Life
Foundation okay that case see you later
those turtles carry salmonella by the
way hand sanitizers over in Aisle three
this is that same bodega where he goes
all crazy on the person that's trying to
rob mrs. C and that's just her
character's name in the movie they're
just calling her mrs. C so she chases
him down after this scene here where
Eddie accuses him about killing people
in these governmental tests and he's
like that's it end of interview get out
of here so she chases him down as
there's no wait wait wait you're right
about all this this is when he gets the
symbiote because when he comes back to
his apartment he's all groggy headed
like oh what just happened this is so
crazy he starts to hear this
MBO speaking in his head and it tries to
start giving him advice don't open that
door who what who's talking to me I told
you don't open that door
so this is that trailer scene where the
symbiote goes into automatic mode taking
control of Eddie's body and taking down
these villains from the live foundation
I think the funny thing here is that the
symbiote has a sense of humor what are
you doing I'm putting my hands up you're
making us look bad no I'm not yes you
are why would you do that because it's
the sensible thing to do so the symbiote
says enough is enough I'm taking the
driver's seat takes down all these
villains then they start to talk to each
other and you get that joke about biting
people's heads off now let's all bite
their heads off and throw them in the
corner Oh God
two piles a pile of bodies and a pile of
heads you get a brief scene where
Carlton Drake is monitoring this from
the live foundation where he sort of
explains that all they have to do is
kill Eddie and as soon as the host is
dead the symbiote will be forced out of
his body so that's sort of their
solution for getting rid of symbiotes
then we get that scene in the alleyway
where he's looking in the car window
seeing the reflection of the symbiote
talking to him and the symbiote explains
all about what its relationship with the
other symbiotes is and why it is that it
needs
Eddie's help what the hell is this are
you a parasite I hate that word parasite
don't know how it works here but where I
come from parasites are filthy thieves
they steal your life and offer nothing
in return
I on the other hand just saved your life
and ask nothing in return do I have a
brain tumor first you call me a parasite
now you're calling me a brain tumor on
my planet that's a good way to get
yourself eaten your planet yes the
planet Clint are that's not a real
planet so they're just trying to
establish some of the backstory for the
symbiotes themselves we come from
another planet has called Clint are the
important thing in that explainer though
about parasites is a zit it's describing
the other symbiotes like say scream or
riot right is the big one that he ends
up fighting later in the trailer that
takes over Carlton Drake they steal your
life and offer nothing in return I on
the other hand just saved your life so
part of the reason why the other
symbiotes don't like the Venom symbiote
is because they consider it a heretic of
sorts it doesn't believe in their ways
is that they just want to take hosts and
control them themselves using other
organic life forms like humans in this
movie as
meet cars to just go wherever they want
to go the Venom symbiote wants to
coexist and experience life through
another host that's why the term
symbiosis is all about two things
existing in balance with each other so
this whole early part of the film where
he gets the symbiote and the symbiote
has to explain its backstory and why
it's so important that Eddie say yes to
the deal do we have a deal Eddie this is
because the other symbiotes are trying
to kill it so it really needs Eddie's
help to destroy the other symbiotes in
all of Carleton Drake's men are trying
to kill Eddie so the symbiote wants to
help protect him too so that it can
continue to exist
the symbiote is the first one that uses
the term of wee to refer to the both of
them together do we have a deal Eddie we
can do whatever we want and then later I
think the big payoff for that moment is
when he finally stands up and says we
are venom that you hear in all the
trailers when Eddie is saying it but
it's also the symbiote saying at the
same time in one of the really cool
things about the venom character is that
it's sort of a codependent relationship
a lot of comics have gotten into this
because Eddie is great at what he does
but he's a little messed up in the head
and the symbiote is a little twisted
because of its alien morality but the
cool idea is is that you don't totally
know where Eddie's mind ends and the
symbiote begins so when they say we are
venom it's when they've achieved perfect
symbiosis so that it's not say Eddie
just wearing a suit saying we are venom
it's one organism made up of two
different entities in the whole reason
why Carleton Drake is so hot on this is
because he believes that this is the key
to the future of human evolution so he's
the one that's responsible for searching
space for symbiotes once he finds them
he tries to go find more so that's why
it's important to stop him - because you
have a couple on earth and while that's
a big problem it would be way way worse
if you have full-blown Planet of the
symbiotes storyline where a bunch more
come and it would venom eyes the entire
Sony Marvel Universe that would actually
be a pretty badass spin-off movie if
they wanted to do an else world story
hopefully that explains a little bit
about what's going on with the symbiote
its relationship with the other
symbiotes it was kind of what I thought
earlier but it just clarifies that the
prequel comic book just spells it out
and very exact detail so what will
happen is is will probably get another
train
or two before the movie gets here it's
only a couple weeks away so we're not
gonna have to wait that long they've
officially rated it pg-13 I've already
done a video explaining why that is it
has to do with their future plans for a
Tom Hollands spider-man crossover I'll
link that video at the end of this but
they also confirmed that there is a
post-credits scene I've already done
videos about that too it's pretty much
confirmed to be a carnage setup moment
for sequels stuff they haven't said
exactly what they're gonna call the
sequel but the whole idea as you would
probably assume is that venom does
gangbusters they will do more sequels
they have a trilogy plan they've signed
Tom Hardy for three movies so hopefully
after the movie comes out they'll start
talking about what that sequel is gonna
be exactly besides just being venom
versus carnage because that's pretty
much a given at this point but it sounds
like it's gonna be pretty awesome even
if you're not a venom fan it should
still be a pretty cool movie they're
supposed to be dropping the Captain
Marvel trailer early tomorrow morning so
of course if that ends up happening I
will totally do a video for it
congratulations Jason nuyen you're the
giveaway winner for my last big video
please email me on the about page of my
youtube channel so I can get your
details click here to learn about the
venom trilogy that they have planned and
click here for that spider-man far from
home scene thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]